if you're a federal judge and pissed off
the president he tweets at you and you
get to keep your job for the rest of
your life if your attorney picks off the
president you get a podcast quite a
different way of going about hey hey
welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special I'm super excited to
welcome to the show former US Attorney
for the Southern District of New York
host of stay tuned with Preet and the
author of his new book doing justice
pre-prep Preet thanks so much for
stopping by thanks for having me I
really appreciate the book you owe me
dude
I call a lot of people don't care I am I
am well good I'm is Gendry all right
don't start the book is doing justice of
prosecutors thoughts on crime punishment
and the rule of law and it really is
first-rate
for folks who only know you on the right
from the big blowup with President Trump
right firing you or resigning you from
from re fire fire fire you from from the
Southern District of New York what's
been your career path to get to now
being a podcast star so it's not the
ordinary Chris the ordinary career path
but just one thing off the bat thanks
for having me on thanks for mentioning
the book I don't know if you appreciate
this because we move in different
circles but my book came out the same
day your book did and I was very excited
when the New York Times bestseller Lee I
don't love the New York Times when it
comes to the bestseller list right
whether you think it's fake news or not
or failing or not and I was very excited
to tell my family when it first came out
and I got first dibs at seeing it this
book debuted at number four on the
nonfiction bestseller list and I told my
boys and they saw the list and they're
like great but Ben Shapiro beat you and
you debuted number one I know you're
probably modest and don't want to you
know have me remind people but it did
and so I just well you know I've hated
you ever since oh well I really been
yeah I appreciate you mentioning that
and that does give me a surge of warm
why don't you tell me about casting
space so I spent my whole life as a
lawyer and want to be a lawyer you know
from fairly early on stereotypically my
family Indian American immigrant family
my dad was a doctor I was a pediatrician
he was born India I was born in India
I'm an immigrant myself and the dream
for him like it may be in a lot of
and families from that part of the world
not to overly stereotype it was for his
kids to become doctors it's me and my
brother and I was not so good in
chemistry it's not so good in other
science it's not bad in biology but my
path was was towards the law because I
thought that that would be the best way
to make a contribution and then the kind
of law I want to practice after being in
private practice for six years was to be
a prosecutor because I thought it's the
best use of whatever skill set I had as
a lawyer to do good and to protect the
community and uniquely I think among you
know sets of lawyers I have a great
respect for lots of different kinds of
practices that people engage for even
when they leave the law but unlike a lot
of lawyers you don't have to make an
argument you don't agree with you don't
have to take a position that you think
is not just your job every day is to you
to bring a case if you think it's
appropriate to do so and if you don't
think it is then you don't do that
I had an interim period of time where I
worked on the Senate Judiciary Committee
from about 2005 to 2009 then I became
the US attorney and then as you alluded
to the the election went away a lot a
lot a lot of people didn't think was
gonna happen
president Trump got elected and I
assumed that was gonna be out of a job
at some point through a normal
transition process and then I wasn't
because through Senator Schumer he asked
me and then asked to meet with me
personally at Trump Tower in the 26th
floor personally asked me to stay on for
whatever reason we can talk about or not
talking about some months later in March
of 2017
lots of people were asked to resign I
went to make sure that I was being fired
I refused to resign for reason we can
also discuss and then I was gone and
then the question is you know you're a
lapsed lawyer too do you go do the
normal thing that people do which is go
to a big law firm which pretty much
everyone in my position as US attorney
in the Southern District goes and does
bass I guess a little bit on the
circumstances of my departure and for
some other reasons people were
interested in having me write a book
which is really not about the
circumstances of my firing at all I mean
I think Trump appears less in the book
then and then a lot of other people do
most other people and I thought you know
I can take this period of time while I'm
writing my don't how long it took you to
write yours it was for me it was really
hard and I didn't think I could do too
much else while I was doing the book and
I thought my brother
to have a brother who was also laughs
lawyer and started this at this media
company and he had the possibility to be
able to support a podcast and this was
around the time that it seemed to be
clear that there was a constitutional
requirement for people formerly in
government to have a podcast everyone
has a podcast now lots of former federal
prosecutors have a podcast now every
time you look at a TV anchor they also
want to have a podcast and I thought you
know how hard can how hard can it be as
you know it's a lot harder than it looks
and I thought I could write the book and
spend some time doing that and also
speaking you know around the circuit
around the country about things that I
care about and also talk about issues I
care about and have guests and I found
it to be a very rewarding thing bassem
youssef who's this guy who you may know
who had been one of the leading
comedians although he's a doctor by
training in Egypt before the regime
change and he was being harassed a lot
for being this you know outspoken person
exercising his right a free speech which
was not the same as we have here when he
was in Egypt and at one point he had
even more followers than you I think you
have 30 to 35 million viewers a week to
his comedy show and he leaves and then
for a period time he was doing a podcast
with our company and and it occurred to
me to go back to original question why
are you doing what you're doing the arc
of the arc of justice is long but it
bends towards podcasts I think it's
certainly been stored social media fame
I mean I think that's it there's an
obvious truth but let's let's do some of
the the Trump stuff first and then we
can get to some of the deeper ideas in
the book sure because that's obviously
the headline so that's it so what
exactly transpired between the time when
President Trump talked to you and asked
you to stay on and the time when he
asked everybody to resign you among you
among them and so I don't know it was an
extraordinary thing to be asked to meet
with the president-elect of the United
States particularly at that time it was
I think the call that he made to Senator
Schumer came eight days after the
election when presumably other things
were going on and he was still trying to
figure out what his cabinet was gonna
look like and then he asked me to come
meet with him which I did at a time when
he still hadn't picked his Secretary of
State that was that was the week when I
think a day or two before John Kerry had
met with him and had that they
famous dinner where the president has as
normal I think well done steak would
they want that with a1 sauce or ketchup
yeah in a coke so it was a sorta nary
thing that you not seen before
usually these things are handled out of
the Justice Department I never met with
President Obama he never called me once
never had a solo meeting with him ever
during the 7 and 1/2 years that I served
under him 7 years I served under him so
you know it was a compliment I thought
to the office I thought it was a
compliment to the work that we had been
doing and his appreciation of the work
that we have been doing so the weird
thing that happened that I've talked
about it on stay tuned my own podcast is
he began calling me from time to time
which is Augie in the middle of the
meeting different name by the way I've
made this very clear he was very
gracious he was very warm he was very
nice about everything said he had
followed the work of the office it is
still a little strange he's asking to
meet with me and I was prepared as other
people have said they were prepared to
do Jim Comey whatever you think of him
to walk out of the room if he said
something untoward or he crossed some
line which he did not do but at some
point in the middle of the meeting and
Steve Bannon was there I remember him
you Jack and Jerry Jared Kushner was
there so that you know the four of us an
odd group of four people retrospect if
you think about it you know talking
about the office and at some point
Donald Trump the president-elect pushes
posted Pat over across the desk and
asked me to put my phone number on it
my cell and my office number so might
the president like is asking me for my
digits which is kind of strange
um and I'm thinking you know someone
must have my phone number because
someone arranged the meeting through a
phone call so I didn't quite get what
that was about
nobody seemed to think that was odd and
so I Trump does his thing man I well it
now it makes a lot more sense now we
know about the calls and he makes he we
know that he will call the Park Service
and he picks up the phone and that's
sort of an mo for him and maybe that's
okay and maybe that's more normal when
you're talking about certain agencies of
the government you're talking about a
private business it's a little bit
different to be noticed that well the
President himself soon to be the
President himself has a direct line and
cell phone number of the city and I
state's attorney in the Southern
District who has by the way
not for nothing jurisdiction and we see
in hindsight that that you know was used
over things like the Trump foundation
the Trump Organization various
properties all sorts of things business
associates and business interests in in
New York right so I didn't think that
much of it until a few weeks later in
December I was visiting Rikers Island
there's a whole chapter in the book
about art trying to reform Rikers Island
in the disaster that that place is so I
was without my phone and I come back and
I find that the president-elect has
called so I was like that's kind of odd
and it could be you know just polite it
could be something else and you know you
when you're in my line of work and
you're a trained lawyer you know your
spidey sense you know tickles a little
bit and you want to make sure that
you're not gonna get yourself in trouble
and by the way you want to make sure
you're not gonna get the other person in
trouble I mean usually it's the case
that when an elected official or a
person who's about to take over some
office of a political type is making a
phone call to someone who's responsible
for enforcement of the law the person
who's doing the bad thing or who look
like they're doing the bad thing or
crossing some line or maybe giving the
appearance of impropriety is the
politician it's usually not the it's not
the prosecutor although it can be so I
talked about it with some people in my
office my top deputy I notified the head
of transition for the Department of
Justice for Trump and let them know this
has happened and we agreed that for
various reasons including that he wasn't
yet the president the last meeting had
gone without incident and he hadn't
mentioned anything that I could call him
back but I made sure I had a pad and a
pen in case something weird happened and
he shot the breeze or he's like how's it
going if he was should be aware by the
way I'd never met Don Trump before we
had that meeting at Trump Tower I no
relationship with him never correspond
with him had never been in the same room
with him as far as I know so it's a it's
an addition call um made a note of it I
thought it was on I think well he's
gonna be busy going forward you know
it's a big job this is before I knew
about executive time and he he called
again two days before the inauguration
I'm thinking you must have a lot of
other things to do include including
writing your inauguration speech and
again he shot the breeze he boasted
about some things
and I thought I hope this this ends and
I hope he doesn't keep calling me
because it's sort of awkward
I made the notifications at the time as
well and I sort of put to the side the
issue of what I would do if he actually
called me when he was the president
States and I also thought well it's not
as much of an egregious violation
potentially because there's no Attorney
General to go through the ordinary
protocol would be for everyone's
protection and for good appearance
purposes is if there's some reason for
there to be a communication it's
appropriate and not about a case and not
saying like lay off somebody and not
saying go after somebody which would be
inappropriate and potentially criminal
I'm not saying that was you would try to
route that through proper channels you
know the Attorney General the Deputy
Attorney General to talk to the local
United States attorney in Manhattan fast
forward to March 9th of 2017 I was away
from my desk my assistant was gone for
the day
and I got a message from the president's
personal assistant at the present United
States saying would you please return
the call of the President Trump so now
I'm thinking this is a little bit
different this is the third phone call
he's now the president there's no notice
of it we have no business together the
Attorney General has not looped in at
all there have been all sorts of reasons
to be concerned about you know from an
appearance perspective of what it would
look like if you have somebody who a lot
of people thought should be investigated
for various things having direct you
know off-the-record behind the scenes
unprecedented conversations with the
United discerning with jurisdiction
those places so I paused and I don't
make may seem odd to a lot of people and
I've had these arguments with folks so
it takes a little bit of length of time
to explain you know ostensibly he's your
boss you serve at the will of the
president United States he's the only
reason why you've continued on for
another term in your job he asked you he
calls you you call him back it's the
height of rudeness and obnoxiousness not
to call him back and I appreciate all
this I wasn't trying to be rude I wasn't
trying to be disrespectful but you have
to consider a couple of things one you
know I had to worry that I think has
been borne out this is my perspective
not every one of your of your viewers
and listeners will agree with this that
he does not tell the truth about
interactions he's had with people and I
turns out I you know I was never in the
Situation Room with him I'm not a morosa
but he it turns out like everyone who's
had an interaction with a trump
including his closest allies like his
personal lawyer and staff members take
some precaution and want to make sure
that they create their own record of an
interaction with the present so I had
that concern going on
I had the concern going on even if he
it's an innocuous conversation for five
or ten minutes and that later came out
that the sitting president was talking
to the local United States attorney with
jurisdiction over various things at the
same time the people were filing their
emoluments Clause civil suit and calling
for investigation of other things
whether there have merit or not
if it later came out that Preet Bharara
and Donald Trump were having these side
conversations that are really not usual
or typical at all and there was no
documentation of what the conversations
were about how is that going to look not
just for me how's it going for the
president it's not gonna look very good
so we consulted with protocols and
thought well in the absence of knowing
what it's about probably we shouldn't I
know I shouldn't speak to him and what
also is lost on a lot of folks who just
say you know you're fired disgruntled
guy and linger obnoxious and rude not to
return the call the president I called
Jeff Sessions office before I made a
final decision and he wasn't there and I
talked to his his chief of staff
Jodi Hunt and I had a frank conversation
with Jodi Hunt he was very clear to me
that no one else at the Justice
Department no one just Berman knew that
the president was calling me or why he
was calling me and that's also weird
and should for a normal person raise red
flags and he agreed with me that not
knowing what's going on again again for
the protection of the president and the
White House probably best to say unless
you know what it's about unless it can
be you know arranged through proper
channels and when Jeff Sessions is back
in town it's the wise thing not to talk
directly to the present and the other
thing is hanging over all of this which
people maybe forget when they say well
the president doesn't know protocols and
he's just being the kind of guy he is he
does you know how you know he knows
about protocols and why it's it's it's
damaging and potentially disastrous
for politicians and law enforcement
people to talk offline when there's a
pending case because he campaigned on
that issue again and again and again at
rally after rally after rally ringing in
my ears when he kept making the point
that Loretta Lynch sitting on an
airplane on the tarmac at an airport got
a surprise visit from then former
President Bill Clinton who's why
Hillary Clinton was under investigation
by the same Justice Department the Reta
Lynch was leading and you know what it's
it you know the earth exploded
rhetorically and otherwise when they had
their meeting and Donald Trump said and
a lot of people agree with this you know
it's not a completely unfair point I
think he overstated it a lot and I
believe the integrity of Loretta Lynch
and I believe they would not have had an
untoward conversation about the
investigation Donald Trump went to rally
after rally after rally saying about a
private offline conversation between
Loretta Lynch and Bill Clinton obviously
that must have been a thing about
Hillary Clinton obviously that's a
corrupt conversation although no record
exists of that conversation and I'm
thinking to myself now the president is
calling me not quite the same situation
but it's pretty parallel and I thought
you know what for everyone's sake don't
return the call even though I knew at a
minimum that it's gonna piss him off
because he think highly rude and then 22
hours later the phone call came in from
the Acting Deputy Attorney General
asking me to resign and saying that he
had been asked to call all of the hold
over Obama gives attorneys and asking
him to resign so I said something that
maybe seems I've gone on some length you
can interpose a question anytime you
want I said not trying to sound you know
obnoxious been like I are you sure that
applies to me because I had that whole
thing at Trump Tower and he took my hand
and he said can you stay another term
and to my understanding nothing has
changed no circumstance but maybe the
call was about that I have no idea so
until I knew specifically because I do
think whatever you think left to right
there's a decent amount of incompetence
at the White House in rolling out new
measures whatever you think of the
Muslim ban the travel ban from that you
know eighth day in the presidency they
had not fought it out someone someone
woke up and goes to a meeting and says
we're gonna announce a travel ban and
nobody had thought about certain things
like well what if you have a green card
and you're on your way back to the
country what do you do with those people
and I have to keep amending those plans
and so I I also didn't want to resign a
job that I loved dearly and I thought
you know what's going okay by accident
because that's kind of embarrassing hey
kids guess what I resigned it I wasn't I
didn't need to and and that would be
that so I just wanted clarity that the
person who asked me to stay Donald Trump
personally
to face which ordinarily wouldn't happen
in the absence of that I would've been
on my way but I wanted clarity that the
person given know have you been around
the block and I wanted to just the
record to be clear the person who asked
me to stay invited me into his office
and look me in the eye and said you know
implored me to stay but he wanted me
gone and if you want to be gone I'll go
I've took 24 hours you know to get that
clear statement and then I went so in a
second I want to ask you about whether
you believe that president Trump's
behavior here is an exhibition of
corruptness
or is it just an exhibition of he
doesn't know what he's doing you
referred to that briefly a little more
clarity on that
in just one second but first if you're
worried about government failures market
instabilities a lot of folks are rushing
to bond some people are walking to
precious metals maybe you should be
considering things like Bitcoin well
what is Bitcoin bitcoin is just a
limited resource that can't really be
devalued by central governments because
blockchain protects it from devaluation
recently Bitcoin prices rose after China
devalued its currency and markets tanked
as I once said Bitcoin can be a hedge
against government failure we can now
see how this could become a real
alternative to gold for me the place to
trade crypto is eToro here's why eToro
is smart crypto trading made easy eToro
social trading platform has over 11
million active traders and facilitates
over a trillion dollars in trading
volume per year globally you can access
the world's best crypto currencies
they've got 15 different coins available
they've got low and transparent fees
they've got advanced charting features
for smart strategy building and most
important you can try before you trade
I'll give you a virtual portfolio with
$100,000 budget so you can see how the
whole thing works never miss a trading
trend with charts pricing alerts Social
Feeds sign up today at eToro calm /
appear oh that's ETO ro calm / capiro
eToro calm / Schapiro any opinions
expressed do not constitute investment
advice so one of the things that I've
experienced just as a person who's
watching both the Obama administration
and the Trump administration from the
outside is a feeling that these are
obviously administration's that operate
incredibly differently people will say
things to me like well you know if Obama
had said X and Trump says this then
you'd have been up in arms and sometimes
I think that's true because you know
Barack Obama was a much more serious
human being and Trump
meaning that Barack Obama was a person
who actually considered through the
things that he said and then when
said them he usually meant them where is
Donald Trump is a person who has
impulses and then he just speaks the
impulse and then the impulse sometimes
doesn't mean anything at all and
sometimes it's just hidden sounding off
and so coming from the legal world you
know not nearly to the same extent that
you are but obviously but I am a lawyer
it I understand that the focus on on
protocol I understand everything that
you're saying about the weirdness of a
person breaking protocol and that
looking suspicious and creating the the
appearance of suspicion do you think
that actually this is attributable
Trump's behavior here was attributable
to actual corruption or do you think
that it or attempted corruption or do
you think that it's attributable to the
fact that he literally does not know
what he was doing especially at the
beginning of his job but even now he
violates protocol on a racist I think
it's actually a complicated question
because those things are not necessarily
mutually exclusive right there
in lots of cases whether you're talking
about political corruption or you're
talking about bank robbery or anything
else there can be a combination of
actions that people take that are you
know with intended purpose corrupt
purpose and also a lot of incompetence
that goes on and so you can read things
into people's behavior better maybe you
know unfair to read into their behavior
if you're asking with respect to me I've
never made any accusation or allegation
at all that anything with respect to my
dismissal was untoward or corrupt or to
you know stop any investigation or
anything else I don't know what I do
believe to be true as I've said as I
said in relating the story about Loretta
Lynch is that you know I think we give
Donald Trump not enough credit when we
say well he's new he does know he's
doing because he knew to attack Loretta
Lynch for doing precisely what he was
essentially asking me to do which is to
have separate conversations with him the
second thing we know is in hindsight if
you credit it which I do is that on more
than one occasion he met alone with Jim
Comey and one of the times that he met
with Jim Comey then the director what
did he do first
he kicked everyone else out of the room
and he said again if you believe it or
not I leave it to other people to decide
that but the allegation is he thinks
everyone out of the room why do you do
that because you know common sense tells
you because you don't want them to hear
the thing you're saying because maybe
you have some consciousness that it's a
bad thing to do intense can you lay off
Michael Flynn or can you offer me your
personal loyalty so to that extent
I think when we ask the question does he
know what he's doing I think in some
regard he does the other thing I'll say
about his interactions with me and I'd
only make this about me in the book it
has nothing to do with that stuff
because they're bigger issues in the
world and I bear no ill will to anyone
based on my my departure of having a
great life I did that job longer than I
had any reasonable expectation to do it
dream job of a lifetime seven and a half
years but he operates in a certain way
in business transactionally and you know
based on what I've seen and how he deals
with other folks I don't know that he
was gonna say anything untoward in that
call what I believe it and it's my
reasonable speculation that had I
indulged it right and taken the call and
said hey what's going on and developed a
personal separate odd secret
relationship so to speak because they're
not going to be doing a press conference
on the fact we're gonna do a readout of
my call with the president is tates like
like leaders of countries do but if I
continued that and based what I've seen
for two-and-a-half years since that time
what's the likely you tell me what is
the likelihood is a fair question
six months later seven months later he
hasn't referred to someone's Michael
Cohen and he's not gonna call please
like I'm a team player he cultivates
people he was trying to cultivate Jim
Comey I think he was trying to cultivate
me and maybe wouldn't have the call
would never have come but you never know
and and months later when I'm looking at
something or he has someone that he's
you know unhappy with would he think to
make sort of an odd remark and say you
know what's going on with that case and
by that time by the way what does it
look like you know you've taken four
calls from the president you've been
chummy with him maybe you met with him
in the Oval Office maybe you had dinner
if you're the austere native FBI
director or whatever and now you say mr.
president no now you've gone too far and
you sound the alarm bells and you go to
the inspector general or whatever and
take whatever precautions need to take
you don't have a lot of credibility then
it's really important to have distance
and independence I think in these
matters that people have some some faith
in confidence so yeah on the one hand I
think he blunders forward on the other
hand I think he's more cunning and
conniving than people think and whether
or not that's true you still have to
protect yourself and your own
credibility our job so for me I mean
look the mother rapport we can talk
about that also there's lots of things
people bike and don't like it but the
one thing that you've seen the model
report over
again just continuing this theme of
conversations Donald Trump's owned
hand-picked lawyers and staff you see in
the report
tell him over and over again please
don't cry stop please don't call Jeff
Sessions about that please don't have
this meeting with Jim Carr just don't do
it so it's not like Preet Bharara
appointed Bart by Barack Obama who is
now a critic of the president saying oh
it's a terrible thing he made those
phone calls his own people we're telling
him over and over and over again there's
some things you shouldn't do so this
raises a slightly different question but
I think more in stood but
institutionally related and that is what
should the relationship be like between
the president and the DOJ generally so
there's been a lot of criticism of for
example bill Barr and his relationship
with but the president particularly
aftermath of the Mulla report but people
on the right I think correctly point out
that Eric Holder declared himself Barack
Obama's wingman as the Attorney General
was a bad thing so you shouldn't have
said that and there was this feeling
that I mean obviously the President does
get to appoint the Attorney General that
under unitary executive theory all these
people work for the president so how
independent should the DOJ really be
from the presidents of the United States
given the fact that that effectively
means they're not answerable to anyone I
mean that's owned dependent to the
president and their Independence of the
legislature what how does that work so I
think it's I think it's both complicated
and also very simple right and I think
people conflate two things you have all
these agencies in the government and
they're supposed to put forward the
policy and the priorities of the
president that is the president's right
and he chooses the heads of those
agencies with advice and consent you
know the Senate has to approve so it's
not right you know you can't do end runs
like he's trying to do with vacancies
the Senate has to be involved who
doesn't get his his full unadulterated
choice for every position in government
but he gets a lot of deference and every
president has the problem is that the
Justice Department doesn't have just a
policy function it has uniquely pretty
much an enforcement function right so
perfectly appropriate for the president
states no matter who the Attorney
General is or who the FBI director is to
have regular contact about keeping the
country safe about saying you know
talking about if there's an epidemic of
gun violence
hey mr. Attorney General you know what's
going on with this are we expending
enough resources should we go to Capitol
Hill and ask for more money should we be
adopting different legislation there's a
lot of back and forth between
subdivisions of the
Department of Justice and the White
House to talk about what laws they can
both to get together and support to make
sure that we're being protected against
outside threats you know you know
national security protecting the
homeland you know there's an important
reason why the president gets briefed
every day and the FBI and the Department
Justice are a part of that all of that
is good all that is appropriate you
wouldn't want that to go away I think it
would be a disaster for public safety
for the country on the other hand what
you cannot have and what you should not
have is not just from a president no
senator no governor no mayor no
president should ever be able to pick up
the phone and with the weight of that
office direct you know yeah I'm gonna
make the US Attorney for a moment US
attorney Ben Shapiro hey I want you to
prosecute that guy named X because I
don't like him I mean I'll just make it
more a more extreme example everyone I
think understands that if the president
calls up and says go prosecute that
person which you know you see echoes of
that that's bad or to be inquiring as to
the timing of of cases because it might
help them for political reasons or to
say to lay off somebody listen can can
you see your way clear like you did with
Michael Flynn which whether or not
that's an indictable offense of
obstruction I don't know anybody who
thinks that's that's okay that's a good
thing to do and certainly puts him in a
bad light so there's a separation
between sort of policy and resources and
overall you know rowing in the same
direction if a president decides that he
thinks that his Department of Justice
should be I think you know more
aggressive on opioid enforcement great
if the president I say it says hey you
know what there's an actor in Hollywood
that I don't like very much you know
think about with you not you can do a
raid on that person's house he's doing
you know he's driving me crazy you know
can you go raid Alec Baldwin's house no
we want to increase drug enforcement
that guy looks like he's on drugs and
when he's on SNL I'm making all this up
you know please no letters go raid his
home everyone understands that the first
thing is okay increasing enforcement
priorities and the second thing is
absolutely not and you know there's some
gray I guess in the middle of those two
things but not that much and that's
where the violations take place so that
that raises a slightly separate question
which is as a prosecutor how do you
decide which crime
to prosecute and this goes more to the
thing with your brother because you know
obviously the what comes to mind in the
in the sort of trumpian context is there
were statements that were made upon the
election of New York's Attorney General
Letitia James where she was stating that
her first priority was to go after the
Trump Organization or it was a high
priority to go after or after to
investigate the Trump Organization and I
thought to myself well shouldn't you
actually just be uncovering like the
crime and then figure out exactly who it
is that you're targeting how do you make
the decision what is a case worth
targeting and are targeting the case are
you targeting somebody who you suspect
of criminality so it depends on the
circumstance but generally generally
speaking and in the vast majority of
cases prosecutors are supposed to be
investigators that they work with are
supposed to be looking at crimes so some
guy is dead on the street there appears
to be a bullet hole you investigate
because a crime it seems has been
committed who has committed the crime it
wasn't that it was president Trump and
oh yeah that's totally fine I don't he
gets away with it right thanks for
reminding us about or I'll give him a
complicated situation which we
encountered all the time out of the blue
the CEO of a company resigned financial
institution resigns and there's suddenly
a restatement of earnings no
tremendously huge change from before
that raises red flags probably you know
folks in my office would would jump on
it immediately and start issuing
subpoenas or making some phone calls to
see if a crime has been committed and if
so what crime and who is responsible for
those things that's all that's all well
and good there's a and so when people
say you should be targeting a crime not
not the not a person that is generally
correct but there's another there's an
area where that's actually not fully
true that people I think respect and
appreciate and would support and that is
with organized crime you know we had a
much bigger organized crime problem in
America than we then we've had recently
although they're still out there we were
still doing mob cases including
traditional Lakota Nostra Italian mafia
cases once upon a time in New York at
least there was a separate squad for
each of the five traditional Italian mob
families we don't have five anymore but
there they're still agents who work
every day on trying to combat the crimes
they're committing
now in that circumstance because there
has been evidence overtime gathered by
law enforcement the particular people
identify
people who were members and associates
and took you know an oath of a murder
and everything else within families
there's a targeting of them and in fact
I didn't explore there's so much in the
book because I ran out of space but that
that presents actually this interesting
question as to the principal right do
you look at a crime and see who
committed it or is it appropriate in
certain circumstances like with the mob
if you're gonna make any effort that's
gonna be successful to get rid of them
and to stop their you know their bad
conduct and their harassment of people
and their you know terrorizing people in
their communities
you've sometimes so long as you have
evidence that there's reason to believe
that it is in fact a racketeering
enterprise then like you know like they
did during Prohibition you look at the
person and then you start you know
following them and you do surveillance
of them and you find out who their
associates are and you have the people
one of whom I described in the book
Kenny McCabe you know we're the best mob
investigators detectives of all time
first arrest I think of John Gotti was
done by Kenny McCabe he's the guy that
you sometimes see in movies who would go
to the funerals and he would go to the
weddings and the christenings and take
pictures of people to show the
Association so just to be you know fully
frank there are those limited
circumstances in which you know based on
good faith understanding of criminal
activity in a criminal enterprise you do
target the person like John Gotti was
was targeted by law enforcement based on
his identity and belief there was him he
was involved in things not just you know
somebody that John I didn't like once up
dead did John Gotti do it
it's both of those things so I think a
lot of critics on the right who look at
for example the the molar report and the
molar investigation the what they would
say is that this was Annie McCarthy had
suggested missed any McCarthy by the way
was my I don't you know this who I
disagreed on a lot of things in our old
age he was my one of my first
supervisors of s team yeah I think you
told me that at one point in and he said
he's made the case that the Trump Russia
investigation was initiated in bad faith
that it was basically initiated in an
attempt to dig up material on Trump's
team and that it was out of control now
he and I actually disagree on some of
this I've suggested that I think that it
was probably initiated in good faith and
that even if there is evidence that the
FISA warrants were
exaggerated for purposes of going after
a Carter page for example or if I feel
that the the obstruction investigation
that was an outgrowth of the Trump
Russian investigation became the center
of the investigation as opposed to the
original counterintelligence that sort
of my take but the the overall
right-wing critique is that this was an
attempt to go after Trump on a personal
level not an attempt to go after a
particular crime and that the
obstruction and the focus on obstruction
is in in effect a secondary crime it was
Trump if it was crime at all that it was
a it was an attempt by Trump to kick
back against the lack of presence of an
of an original nexus of crime meaning
that the first half of the model report
is all about Trump Russia there's no
real allegation in that half of the
report that criminal activity took place
there's a lot of ugly activity and stuff
you wouldn't like but there's a lot I
think I think just more precisely there
was a conclusion there was insufficient
evidence to say the the crime had been
established
right which is not really a
prosecutorial standard right I mean it
is in the sense on rate Trump but the
the question wasn't no but it sort of
does Dorothy know by implication he's by
implication he actually sort of is
exonerated in this in the criminal law
sense right of the crimes were being
investigated in volume 1 and we know
that by implication why because in
volume 2 he says we're not exonerating
you so so if you didn't say it and
wanting a maximal of construction from
law school if you can say exonerate it
into and you didn't say the same thing
in one essentially kremlings all right
what does that mean it's excused or it's
wonderful behavior and people should be
proud of it
with respect to your question about the
origins I mean I tend to agree with you
I think it was done in good faith
because it doesn't make a lot of sense
to me that the people who I think you
don't have any great reason to suspect
their motives would be going after the
present for the sole reason of going
after the president and we have I think
an inspector general report and others
that are looking at the the origins of
the investigation and so on to prejudge
that and we can talk about that again
when that when that comes out yes I
don't I don't know that that's that
holds a lot of water what do you make of
the the final outcome of the Moller I
will say just further to your point you
know Bob Muller himself
I don't think anybody has any basis to
say that he was in it to sort of somehow
destroy our demolished Trump and I said
that for a few is one it's not the
character the person that I've known
pretty well for a long time
number two I think in a lot of ways he
bent over backward I mean look a
different special counsel a lot of
people are upset who were Trump
supporters with with Bob Muller but a
different special K Ken Starr for
example would have written a completely
denied saying him in particular but I
can start like person more even Jim
Comey for that matter and any one of a
number of other people who if they if
they wanted to could have massively hurt
Donald Trump in a way that a lot of
Trump opponents wished for prayed for
and craved and he didn't do that right
so there's it's an odd argument for
people to say but the leader of this
special counsels office was really out
to get Trump and all these angry
Democrats and at the end of the day he
didn't harm him in the way that people
wanted because I think he held back he
held his fire people would ask me the
question and I would try to correct them
cuz I think you're right to worry about
this issue because too many people in
the country whether they don't like
Hillary Clinton or they don't like
Donald Trump
they will chant lock him up and lock her
up because because they want their they
want their prosecutors in these high
stakes cases to be substituted for you
know a political result right there
they're relying you know what couldn't
happen at the ballot box it is maginot
they're looking for people all the time
I think that's not what Muller is in it
for people that ask me the question do
you think Muller is gonna get Trump I
said I don't know what that means but
that's not his job and if he's thinking
about it in terms of getting Trump then
he shouldn't be in it his job going to
what you're saying first was just to see
what the truth is see what the facts are
there was evidence and I think nobody
disputes this and it's now been
basically confirmed by everybody
although Trump seems not to like the
conclusion there was Russian
interference in the election that that's
like the dead body with the bullet in it
who did something about it was it an
accident you know
was it self-inflicted let's find out
what the facts are and I that's how I
think about in some ways the origin of
the investigation there was this there
was his interference it was really bad
who's responsible for it in Russia you
know what country did it and if it's
Russia which people in Russia did it and
you know god forbid
whether any Americans involved and among
all the Americans in the country the
subset of people who were working on the
Trump campaign did they have anything to
do with it and will and will see people
would ask me what do you think you know
mullahs gonna be done do you think he
has a timetable and I would say this is
early on
I have no idea and B I hope he has no
idea because if he does that he's
prejudging something when people ask me
why I did a lot of high-profile
investigation some of which I talked
about in the book nothing on the scale
of investigating you know a presidential
candidate like Hillary Clinton or or
Donald Trump but you know I investigated
my office investigated the mayor the
city of New York Democrat the governor
of the state of New York Democrat the
Speaker of the New York State Assembly
Democrat and the Senate Majority Leader
in New York Republican right we went
after everybody possibly more Democrats
and Republicans over my tenure um two of
them got indicted and went to prison and
two of them and two of them didn't and
in all those circumstances you just the
job is not to go after somebody the job
is to see what the evidence shows and
then follow the facts where they may
lead and and that and that's it and
people would ask me all the time when
are you gonna be done when he gonna be
done and they would predict that there
was gonna be an indictment or not and
you don't know
and as I reciting the book I had many
sections on just the whole sort of
exciting business of investigating
something and there are times and
investigations including one we did of
the Speaker of the New York State
Assembly Sheldon Silver were early in
the investigation my team would come
across some great evidence they would
come and they would talk about this
evidence and it would sort of make us
think that the likelihood of charging
this longtime you know essentially
ultimately we were able to prove corrupt
party boss Democratic Party boss in New
York the likelihood of charging him was
was growing and then you would realize
you know what I think we overstated the
value of that evidence because we talked
to some other people and this is the
process of coming to any conclusion
about anything at all and I presume that
the Muller team did something like this
and then later some other evidence
doesn't seem that important and then it
grows in value because you finally find
a witness to corroborate what that
person is saying and ultimately you
sometimes build a case you sometimes
don't but you never pre-charge and I
don't have a basis for thinking that was
standing some some evidence to the
contrary the bulk of evidence think the
evidence I think suggests that that it
began in good faith and it continued in
good faith and what do you make of the
second half of the report
because that's where obviously all of
the fire has been focused is on the
obstruction half of the report and I
will say that I do agree with the
critique that it's it's very bizarre to
release a full two hundred page report
about all the things that somebody does
wrong explicitly acknowledging from the
very beginning that you have no capacity
to recommend indictment or not it's
almost a parentless situation when James
Comey came out and proceeded to read
Hillary Clinton the riot act and then
explain why he listened process he got
fired for that remember that's the
reason Jim come he got fired because he
didn't reportedly yes of course yes of
course because Donald Trump is deeply if
it's very confusing my head start
spinning so yeah exactly but but there
were critical of Comey at the time for
saying like you don't get to spell out
all the reasons why you think somebody
did all this bad stuff there and then
say and we're not prosecuting because
you're not prosecuting the prosecutors
job is to either prosecute or not
prosecute so that that I talked about at
some length in the book this principle
that you have a binary choice as a proxy
as an ordinary prosecutor you have a
binary choice you charge you don't
charge and if you try and you can judge
the actions of the prosecutor and and
the law enforcement investigative agency
NYPD FBI DEA whatever when they bring a
case and then the bench appears of the
world and the pre bars of the world can
in their leisurely way pick at it
because there's a public document
there's a public proceeding there is a
judge there's an adversary you know
under the Constitution you were required
to provide counsel even if the defendant
can't afford it and everyone can make
their arguments whether they're lawyers
or not and then go on television they
can write columns and they can say and
then you can also make a judgement if
the jury rejects the prosecution's case
and acquits the defendant more basis for
saying it was an overreach and everyone
can have I think a pretty you know
thoughtful intelligent discussion about
whether that case was fairly broad or
not the problem is sometimes you don't
bring the case and in circumstances
where you don't bring the case but
everyone knew you were looking at the
case like happened with some
high-profile people in my state that we
were looking at then a lot of questions
because you can't judge it in the same
way and because the prosecutors hands
are tied and their lips should be sealed
right um you haven't seen the grand jury
material so there's a person
you know money has been paid or a hotel
has been built and people think well how
did that person get favorite treatment
if it's a public corruption case or in
other cases that are there you know very
fraught these days there's a cop he
shoots an unarmed it turns out to be an
unarmed young african-american kid and
how could that happen the crime must
have been committed why did you not
charge and then what creeps into the
minds of ordinary good faith citizens is
was there something at play here was it
politics was it incompetence was it
racism was it because Trump wanted this
or Trump wanted that and then and then
you worry about those cases but the
problem for the prosecutor is when you
decide to decline not bring a case there
is an impulse and clearly Jim Comey who
once upon a time worked for and I have
respect for and I think he tells the
truth even though he's made mistakes he
was he was on the horns of a dilemma not
the way he describes a dilemma but it
was in his mind for good-faith reasons
Hillary Clinton should not have been
charged based on how other similarly
situated people have been treated under
that particular statute over time and he
I get this because I had the same forum
and trust me I've gotten a lot of
criticism for cases that I brought and
for cases that I didn't bring and he
thought to himself look if people just
understand that I'm a good faith actor
here and the FBI which I love and adore
and appreciate and respect revere even
they didn't do anything wrong like what
bothered him I think and it bothered
it's bothered me many times in case that
I you know have had to oversee I don't
want them to think that this was
political I don't them to think they
didn't do it by the book so I'm gonna
say all this stuff and be fair monument
be open and open about it I get you know
a while when we close those cases you
know learning a little bit from that
example we're confirming our view from
that example when you close a case that
everyone knows has been opened
especially involves a political figure
and people have views about that person
not based on the law not based on some
transgressions but based on their view
of whether or not that person should be
an office or not because they like their
policies or not or they trust them or
not or they voted for them or not you
got to keep your mouth shut because it
causes a lot of problems but it does it
does lead to unfortunately don't have a
solution for this or an answer this it
leads to this dilemma where
people can't fully trust the decision to
decline now that's the case with all
ordinary prosecutions and the way I
distinguished Muller a couple things
first you know Ramona didn't release the
report president Trump's you know
alleged buddy bill Barr released the
report you know Bill Brock could have
come up with some reason because he
doesn't seem to mind criticism too much
even though there was a full report that
was written five before by bob muller to
bilbao remember we've gone so far in
this whole process the people have
forgotten that one of the original
worries that a lot of people had was is
any of the report gonna become public is
all the convention public his bill bar
gonna you know shuts all down bill bar
made the decision to take this you know
explosive report and particular volume
two and put it out in the public he
could have he did a summary which he did
very cleverly I thought then he puts out
the whole reports it was not Muller I
Muller clearly may have expected that it
becomes public or not but his mandate
Bob Muller's mandate it's a very odd
thing right it's in that I guess my
question is more about the mandate than
there's about mullahs activity meaning
yeah but at a certain point Rinna Muller
I mean at the very outset if he really
believed the DOJ regulations prevented
him from recommending or not
recommending prosecution and that the
president can be prosecuted so long as
he's in office anyway shouldn't even
just said so what am I doing here like
what well so the reason you I never
investigated in case you weren't allowed
to prosecute no look correct and I have
memos like that and those memos get
written all the time I have lengthy
memos that I read all the time the
difference was in the ordinary case and
we'll get to why that's not ordinary in
the ordinary case you're absolutely
right and people should understand this
we're investigating you know the mayor
of a town for example or a police
officer or someone else and their
considerations on both sides and my team
would put together a memo and I would
read it and at the end there would be a
recommendation we would have a
discussion I would say like now I don't
know there's enough evidence on this
stuff can you flesh this out more can
you maybe show me a videotape of that
transaction or whatever the case may be
and then you decide and you either
charge because you think you have enough
or you go home
and nobody ever sees that memo there's
no requirement for anybody to see that
memo because you're talking about an
ordinary citizen and if the prosecutor
can't do anything about that person then
that's the end although there's there
some circumstances in which you think
the prosecutor can maybe refer that
person for disciplinary action or
something else
this is a little bit like that so
because the president uniquely among all
human beings the United States of
America is not according the OLC
opinions right and I'm sure your
listeners are now familiar with is not
subject to being criminally charged
while still in office but the principle
still remains that no one is above the
law
right that there has to be some
accountability well unlike the random
people that I'm talking about in my
hypotheticals who can't be subject to
any other accountability the president
can be on the one hand he has the shield
which is the OLC opinion on the other
hand he has to face the sword a
potential impeachment that's why a lot
of people myself included although I
think the language is more abstruse and
that needed to be in volume too Bob
mother seemed to be saying well he
doesn't say forthrightly and this is I
agree with you on the weirdness of it
and it's totally bizarre on this score
but if you had written it differently
and if he had said I think we maybe have
less of a debate he said look like we
cannot charge the president for these
reasons because the OLC has found that
to be unconstitutional to charge a
sitting president however and he alludes
to this but doesn't say quite this way
however we have uncovered serious
misconduct we have uncovered all sorts
of the things that happen with respect
to obstruction we cannot say that a
crime has not been committed we can I
was on irate the president there is
another body it's called kaku that's
what he was doing yeah maybe it said but
I guess this going back to the original
question which is a good one and a fair
one if he had said those things
explicitly would you still have the same
argument that he should have shut down
on day one because what the hell is he
doing I mean yes because again he's in
the executive branch meaning the
Congress does have its own investigative
tools and having the DOJ under the
unitary executive theory presiding over
the do you have Trump who's presiding
over the DOJ having the DOJ investigate
the president on behalf of Congress is a
very weird situation I mean usually DOJ
is investigating on behalf of the DOJ
it's not investigating on behalf of the
legislative body with its own separate
and unique capacity to to investigate
and if you want to investigate President
Trump for a crime he commits well in
office
well again he's subject to impeachment
that's what Congress is for and if you
want to wait until afterward and you can
prosecute him afterwards there in the
investigation I understand the point
but the problem is this was not a
discrete thing about whether or not
Donald Trump shot someone in Fifth
Avenue and there no other actors no
other participants and you could make in
that circumstance I think you have a
more valid point right like well what
the hell are we gonna do here because we
can't charge the president we're not
gonna do this as a proxy for Congress or
someone else and I kind of get that
because you know at the outset the only
thing we're going to uncover is couple
building on the part the President or
not and that's it and it's a contained
universe right this was not that this
was the farthest thing from a contained
universe there's millions of things are
looking at there's lots and lots of
people both on the Russia side and on
the obstruction side there's lots of
people who might have been implicated
there's lots of people who have been
charged and in the course of doing this
investigation not of the president I
think it's not the right way to look at
it in the course of doing this very
broad I think appropriate investigation
that began I believe in good faith about
interference in an election and looking
at all sorts of people including Roger
stone and everyone else and in the
course of looking at all this stuff
which we write about in volume 1 and in
volume 2 some of the stuff relates to
the president and it'd be kind of an
awkward thing to close your eyes to what
the president was doing while you're
trying to you know tell the story and
figure out all the things that are going
on and then secondly once you have all
this information and you can you gained
all this evidence you know to write a
report that you're supposed to give to
the Attorney General
talking about everybody except the
president on the basis that at the end
of the day you can't charge the
president know what I mean like all
these things are so intertwined
inextricably that I get your point but
it would be an awkward thing to do in
practice so in a second I own ask you
about your record as prosecutor oh and
talk about actual book all right but
first let's talk about all of your data
you know your data may be exposed you
may not even know that your data is
exposed I didn't know my data was
exposed until somebody hacked my credit
card and proceeded to buy NFL tickets
well that's why I started using
expressive VPN expressvpn as an app I
use to stay secure online why should you
care about encrypting your data well
it's often easy for a hacker to bypass
Wi-Fi security and steal your
information by exploiting flaws like
crack that's crack with a K in case you
want Google it it's hard to know whether
your device or network is vulnerable and
if you ever use Wi-Fi or a hotel or a
shopping mall you're sending data over
an open network meaning no encryption at
all the best way to ensure that all of
data is encrypted and can't be read by
hackers is to use Express VPN all you
need to do is download the Express VPN
app on your computer or smartphone tap
one button to secure 100% of your
network data and then just use the
internet the way you normally would
Express VPN is incredibly reliable it's
the fastest VPN service I've tried
they're also rated the world's number
one a TPM provider by review sites like
tech radar and seen it there's a reason
I use Express VPN I want to be protected
so if you want the best in online
security and privacy protection head on
over to expressvpn comm slash been for
three extra months free with them on
your package again that's expressvpn
comm slash Ben to get started ok so
let's talk about your actual record as a
prosecutor so you were an incredibly
famous high-powered prosecutor there's
rumors that the Paul Giamatti character
and billions is based on you you know if
that's true by the way this is a very
fine Indian American actor Paul Giamatti
who'd know for a lot of reasons both
professional and personal I don't think
there's a lot of resemblance between
Paul Giamatti and if you and if you've
watched it if you've watched the show
people your mythology my home life is
different from his home very very
different but but you were obviously
very high powered and you burn a lot of
high-profile cases a lot of those
high-profile cases men will put you on
the cover of Time magazine was an
insider trading case what was your
theory of prosecuting insider trading
how much how much evidence did you did
you feel that you required in order to
prosecute an insider trading case and
also generally people have tremendous
suspicion of Wall Street how prominent
is insider trading I mean if you watch
billions it's every that they're going
poisoning chickens but right today I
don't I don't I don't keep somebody
tapped I think I think it's gone down at
least a certain kind of insider trading
so there are lot of people who suggest
that insider trading is is a victimless
crime I don't think that's true I think
you can have the victimization of
companies who's in whose private
information is being sold on the you
know on essentially black-market
material nonpublic information is being
given to other folks which is undermines
the integrity of their numbers they're
also by the way depending on the nature
of the trade there people on the other
side of the trade know you're making the
trade based on inside information that
the merger is gonna happen or the merger
is not going to happen and there someone
on the other side of that is this who's
this sucker in that and then overall I
think it diminishes people's respect you
know for the market look one thing that
Donald Trump has said that it's correct
a couple things he said correct that
bears on this you know there is a swamp
I don't just don't think he's draining
it and a lot of the system in a lot of
ways is rigged and a little bit you know
I was surprised at how much attention
was brought to bear on the insider
trading cases I've always said not the
most important cases we did nobody died
but they were important and I think part
of the reason people paid a lot of
attention to them is people get very
upset and it resonates with them when
they see people of privilege and wealth
which a lot of these people were if not
all these people there was a billionaire
named Roger Roger had a billion dollars
to have a billion dollars I just closed
unfortunately not yet with this empire
you don't fund a I mean if you call the
advisement behind the scenes on how to
conduct this insider trading of what you
speak then one day but you can disclaim
you have billions that works too and
then you say your tax returns are under
audit so I provide that I've provide
that for makes I'm a billionaire but
there's a person with a billion dollars
and he's still cheating to make you know
a few extra million dollars and that
makes people really angry with respect
to what kinds of proof you need to send
people have said that it's sort of murky
and the rules are unclear in in the
criminal system I think it's very
important to make sure that your cases
are clear they have clear proof of
intent you have clear proof of the
trades that you're saying or illicitly
done and that you have essentially
smoking gun proof of those things and a
lot of insider trading cases that
couldn't be brought I mean in the in
they'll build up to some of these cases
we were bringing because word got out
things were going on for reasons that
are not good without reading the
complaints about read the indictment
some people thought well you're sort of
overreaching Preet Bharara US Attorneys
offices is going too far and they're
going after the gray area I don't think
you look at any of the cases we brought
and we brought scores and scores of
cases it was often really clear common
sense evidence right because remember
and this is sort of parallel to some of
the things we've been talking about with
the mother investigation and arguments
made on behalf of the president you see
a dead body in the street bullet in the
heart and if you can quickly rule out
the person didn't you know die by
suicide then is almost certainly a
homicide unless that's self-defense but
you pretty much ruled everything out so
you know a crime has been committed
because you not supposed to shoot people
on the street but lots and lots of
criminal activity consists of acts that
are by themselves completely lawful not
only completely lawful but part of the
obligation of the actor so
for example it is part of the obligation
of a sitting legislator to vote it is
part of the business plan and perfectly
legitimate capitalist business plan for
a hedge fund to trade to buy a stock to
sell a stock to go long to go short all
those things are legitimate the thing
that makes the kick those cases hard to
prove without some smoking gun proof of
intent what's in the head is that they
can say look we have this research there
were good-faith reasons why we bought
this stock so it's actually incredibly
hard case to make unless you sometimes
have an insider I'll get an example of a
case and people would say you know how
do you know the version of the question
just ask me how do you know when you
have enough to bring a case and when I
talk about in the book we had a guy who
in the wake of this big Wall Street
Journal article that broke on a Friday
evening where the reporter and that
story said that the u.s. tratar office
the US Attorney's Office and the FBI
together we're bringing massive insider
trading cases in the future a guy who
had been engaging in insider trading
decided on lonzell decided that he was
gonna take the flash drive on which he
had inside information and smashed it to
pieces and get rid of it we had no idea
that that happened and would never had
any idea that that happened except for
the fact that later as I described in
the book there was another guy who was
his best man who decided to flip when
approached by an FBI agent who was
leading these investigations and when
that guy flipped months later he went to
the apartment of the person who
destroyed the evidence wearing a wire
and the other person trusted him
shouldn't have and basically got him to
confess that in the night the Wall
Street Journal article came out he took
his flash drive he bashed it to pieces
with pliers he walked out of his
apartment of thing midnight or one
o'clock in the morning in New York City
found multiple garbage trucks who were
in the streets and deposited the remains
of various bits of the flash drive in
those garbage trucks we indicted that
guy and we were able to secure a guilty
plea from him because of this other so
that's the kind of evidence not always
so clear in the absence of having a
wiretap and the absence of having
something you know more direct you need
stuff like that and we also by the way
wasn't my idea people before my time
pioneered the idea of doing wiretap
using the tool of the wiretap to do
trading investigations as well that
gives you the kind of evidence you need
to and is it really all that common
because pretty common I said was rampant
at the time and got a lot of tension
I came over the exact number I think we
brought over a hundred cases and I
thought we were only touching the tip of
the iceberg so I think there not been a
lot of enforcement everything now
there's a generation of insider trading
enforcement under Rudy Giuliani you know
many many years earlier and then there
was this that again began before I got
there then we continued and expanded our
investigations and prosecutions yeah
well look it's common sense when people
are around the opportunity to engage in
that kind of conduct right
they're privat inside information
there's not a lot of policing of the
conveyance of that inside information
and people don't think there's been
enforcement actions either by the SEC or
by prosecutors offices they engage in
the behavior because there's no
punishment and so I like to think you
know the enforcement especially when
you're talking about people who are
privileged and smart and can do with
legitimate cost-benefit analysis it
brings the conduct down and sort of a
policy level as a prosecutor what do you
do when when the law is just a while you
don't like you saw this with President
Obama for Endeca for example just saying
I don't I don't want to prosecute
illegal immigration crimes for dreamers
there are a lot of libertarians out
there who are looking at you know
insider trading laws as you suggest and
they're saying okay well now you just
have free or flow of information in the
market the market now prices and a bunch
of information that was gonna get priced
in anyway it was just priced in sooner
so let's say that you are a prosecutor
you don't like that law what do you
think the obligation is to prosecute
violations of laws that you find
foolhardy so so I don't think that's up
to individual sort of line prosecutors
to make as a general matter you should
not go into that job unless you have a
generalized comfort with enforcing the
laws you know within proper discretion
and and with respect to what justice
requires and I have a whole chapter on
this also right it does not mean that
with respect to every case and every law
and every statute the murder how broadly
written and how one enforced up to that
time that that means you do everything
possible that a prosecutor is capable of
doing legitimately and I say I think
this is true of every prosecutor did
everything they could possibly do when
throw the book at everyone they could
possibly do it
and infinite resources we'd be living in
a hellscape and lots and lots and lots
of people would be you think mass
incarceration is a problem now it'd be
multiple times worse so you have to pick
and choose so I'm one of the few
commentators in America that doesn't
actually think mass incarceration is
giant problems so okay well for another
day right yeah exactly
hey madam prosecutor I do but I have the
luxury being in the federal system where
we had a lot of resources and we could
pick and choose our cases and we could
decide what our priorities were in some
ways we had more resources than your
average DA's office no ways we had less
going to have the resources of the FBI
but you know we didn't have as many
people as for example the Manhattan DA's
office or more Assistant District
Attorney's in the city of New York by
far than there were assistant US
Attorney's in the federal system and we
tried to pick off the big fish so you
decide to pursue what you think is in
the interest of justice based on the
resources you have and the threats to
the public so for example on the issue
of organized crime we talked about that
as enforcement action started to build
some success and the Mafia problem began
to become a little bit less and fewer
bodies were turning up in the Hudson
River you could reduce resources you
could have fewer people working
dedicated to that and I was one of the
people who was dedicated to that when I
was a line prosecutor back in the early
2000s so you can reduce that assignment
you can reduce that the FBI the thing
that was coming up at the time that I
became the US Attorney was cybercrime
not that many people were expert in it
not that many people knew how to
prosecute it not that many people had I
think the technological expertise and
the amount of resources that were
expended on that and by the way those
laws have been on the books for a long
time it's just that you've started to
see much much greater you know much much
greater bad actions by nation-states
Bailleul Zek and these other you know
the activists as they call them and
other people just trying to make a buck
by stealing money out of your bank
account from a laptop in Latvia so you
decide how are you gonna balance your
resources
you got the mob problem you've got a
cyber you know epidemic going on around
the world we'll do a little less here a
little bit more here that means that
maybe some crimes you're not prosecuting
people understand it when you talk about
it in that way right just it's like any
business person has to make a decision
of allocation of resources right some
markets market based analysis I'll give
another area that's less that's less you
know easy to sort of understand
is more controversial because it goes to
the immigration debate so I don't think
of it as you can just sort of forget
about a law because you don't like the
law you have to think about given the
resources you have
should you be expending time and energy
in a particular way so there's lots of
debate about the border and the
separation of children from their
parents which i think is a terrible
thing and does it have to be done that
way
these laws have been on the books for a
long time people keep talking about
there's a law of 1325 and there's a law
18 USC 1326 one is about illegal entry
right right you come across the border
you're not a criminal you've never been
in the country before should you be
thrown in jail should that should you
prosecute that and there's a debate
among the Democrats which a little bit
as an idle debate I will say on whether
you should repeal 1325 and should that
be dealt with civilly or not and then
you have you have subsections of 1326
which is which is the most relevant to
our practice you have a provision that
says if you have been in the United
States and you're undocumented and you
committed a crime a felony aggravated
felony and then you have been prosecuted
for it and then you're deported and then
you've now come back into the country
you can be prosecuted for that now when
you're deciding in New York City where
you have wall street crime and you have
terrorism which is a huge priority in
you have cybercrime and you have the mob
and you have political corruption all
those things and you have only 165
assistant US attorneys how much energy
you're going to expend prosecuting of
human who literally did nothing other
than come across the border and expend
the resources of the government expend
the resources of the Bureau of Prisons
as opposed to just kicking them back out
of the country how do you pick and
choose among that category of person is
violating either the the weakest section
of the statute where's the strongest and
before I got there in this is under
Republican administration the policy
decision was made just in terms of
proper exercise of resources and
exercise of discretion that we would
prioritize the prosecution of people who
were in the country who had already been
kicked out after committing a crime and
we don't have the timer in the same way
but that might be controversial to some
people they might say well you don't
like the law or you know like the
immigration policy it's really a
common-sense application of principles
of resources to the problem
nobody thinks twice if you say and a lot
of offices had this threshold so you
prosecute credit-card fraud I mean often
it's the Secret Service sometimes it's
the FBI and they would say well you know
depending on how much credit card fraud
or bank fraud was at issue we'll take
the case nobody's taking the 340 dollar
bank fraud case it's not because you
don't like that law it's not because you
think that's not worthwhile it's not
because you don't feel bad for that
victim because maybe the person does
have a lot of money 20 or 40 bucks is a
lot for them but every agent I put
because it's the same amount of
Investigation often I put I put an agent
in an AUSA and a paralegal and a
secretary on the 340 dollar credit card
fraud or bank fraud case how many 1
million dollar cases because there's
plenty of million dollar cases I can't
do so I yeah in some ways I think we
over politicize because everyone is so
into politics and about you know Trump
and not Trump and about immigration on
the board or everything else I think we
should allow local prosecutors US
attorneys or otherwise to exercise it as
long as it's in good faith and it's
based on reason and rationality which I
think we both like to decide are we
gonna spend our time going after
turnstile jumpers we're gonna spend our
time going after you know domestic
violence if you're an eight if you're a
DA for example or in my office's case
going after people who just the their
only potential crime is that they're in
the country and they shouldn't be and
they have no record because there's an
opportunity cost and people forget that
when you make decisions like this
there's always an opportunity cost like
there is an opportunity cost separate
apart from I think you know the
violation of decent standards and all of
that there's also to speak in market
terms again an opportunity cost at the
border if you're having people spend all
their time prosecuting those kinds of
cases because you believe in a
zero-tolerance policy so in one second I
have one final question for Preet
Bharara that question is is President
Trump himself a threat to the rule of
law but if you want to hear his answer
you have to be a daily wire subscriber
ass of sexy question so you go subscribe
go subscribe its daily we're calm click
Subscribe and watch the rest of our
conversation there I really appreciate
you stopping thanks really has been a
pleasure and congratulations on the book
thank you so much justice folks you
should go pick it up and then listen to
my podcast 208 in stay tuned to
pre-board I joke
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy boring associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Maynard post-production is supervised by
Alex zingara editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Kamino
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
pedal graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20